yeah thank you I'm heaven OWSLA a
machine learning engineer a big late
Republic and today I would like to share
my journey in preventing journey and
that journey today starts in a casino so
imagine you're going to casino and
there's a slot machine with 1/9 paper
which we call a single one-armed bandit
we also have heard it and talked before
but of course this is fancy casino so
that's that swap machine just have one
lever
we've got multiple leavers and want to
choose which lever gives us the most
money well you can't make a casino of
one single swap machine
you got the whole bunch of slot machines
each one built maybe in a different year
operated by a different operating system
so it's a little more complex situation
and solving that problem is the same as
solving a chair case and I'll show to
you today how that's how those two mesh
together so back to churn churn really
is a revenue drain for companies
companies lose between 2 and 16 percent
of the total revenue every month due to
customers leaving which is also referred
to as churn and therefore it's a really
high priority in our management meetings
they want to do something about it and
what though of course the current age
we're going to use machine learning to
prevent to prevent sure and in different
ways you can so use machine learning to
prevent churn and in common approaches I
see three big issues the first one is to
make a model which actually predicts
churn the second one is to assume
correlation and causation and the third
one is that if you have your model it
tells you what to do actually listen to
it and that's a running example I'll use
that a telco case where I got my most
recent experience so we've got a nice
internet provider giving subscriptions
to a diverse set of customers all in the
consumer markets so we want to prevent
churn the first logical thing you could
do probably is create a model which
predicts churn so we got a historic data
about people who know what a
subscription is how much they paid and
we know whether whether or not they
churned in the next few months we
trained a model on it showing that get
an eye
during vestigation model we've run it
against our whole customer base and then
we get a predicted churn propensity we
know how likely everyone is going to
churn that set of probabilities we then
give to our marketing departments
they'll pick the highest one think about
really creative about thinking about
some treatments to do some campaigns for
example they can well if the customer is
not worth it or scores too low don't do
anything about it they can send them an
email give some information do a
questionnaire they can even call them up
hey how happy are you with a product can
we can I help you with something or we
can even visit them dwarf a door and
I'll check if it may be their Wi-Fi
needs some improvements give them a
Wi-Fi booster this sounds really nice
but actually the final goal we want to
do is to prevent churn but now we
separated in two parts one part data
scientists predicting who's going to
churn and then we have a different
Department finding out ways to retain
those people but the people who are most
likely to churn are not per se the
people who we actually can retain those
might be the people who think the price
is way too high they don't like the
product anymore or I already found a
competition product from a competition
or what we also in Scott is it could be
for example all people moving to an
elderly home they're moving so no way
they're going to extend their incense
subscription so really need to solve
this problem as one whole thing but you
also might think well it can't be that
bad right we've got our really good
marketing departments they will find
ways and these are the examples I just
give probably are just exceptions but
something else else is happening if you
just ignore the treatments you do you
did well if you have your model and it's
gift for some customers really high
score you give those scores to the
marketing departments and it's all start
calling them and for some people there
see quite effective so those are people
who are persuaded after few months those
people were they were traded sauce a few
months they they don't churn so they end
up in your future training data as
Turner's and therefore if you retrain
your model if we learn that I shouldn't
call those people because they have a
low score so actually your model will
learn to not well tell your business to
not call the people who who you actually
can retain inversely the people who they
who the marketing Pardons couldn't
retain lot so-called lost causes
they'll actually turn and end up in your
future dataset as being churner
so a modern I should really give those
people high scores it isn't really
doesn't really help your marketing with
departments so we so the solution is to
solve it as one big chain we want to
prevent churn we need to find out which
things actually prevent you so we are
going to so what you could do is you
predict the churn rate or inversely
retention rate of the every person
conditionally on the treatments they got
so for the people persons who got no
treatment what was their rate of churn
four people got a direct mill and then
you can find out what's the effect most
effective one but as a company you
actually have a special action do
nothing we see if we wouldn't have a
model or don't do anything then we
always do to do nothing action so that
treatment is quite special it's the
baseline in other we're sending
somewhere else and we're choosing
amongst these four no we have already
chosen to do nothing action and we want
to know if changing our choice do
actually doing something has actually
actually a significant effect so as a
business we're not so much interested in
retention rates of the four individually
we want to know the difference between
an uplift or difference in retention
rate between doing nothing and taking
the action like how much does the
probability of being retained is
increased by the owner action and that
difference that increase manzara nice of
retention rates
that's called uplift so this is the
target we are mostly interested in and
of course we well if we have four
predictions we can quite easily
calculate what is okay it doesn't really
matter however if you have a model
in outputs for example prediction rate
the retention rate for that email and
you subtract from it and you're going to
subtract from it the retention rate of
doing nothing both of those prediction
will have a certain error range if you
then subtract those two values the error
range will actually be added while your
values are subtracted from each other so
the error rate on your uplift will be
higher wisely be the combination of the
two errors of your individual
predictions so doing that that side step
will actually make your prediction
really bad so there so it's much better
to to directly predict uplift and that's
can be done something called the
transform outcome trick which I'll come
back to in a minute and it's described
in this paper because not well we can do
different treatments but those
treatments actually have different
prices sending them sending an email is
way cheaper than visiting someone with a
mechanic truly physically visiting
someone so we want also to taking into
account those prices and also some
customers have a really expensive
subscription and other ones have really
cheap one so what we can do is we can
take uplift which is like the increase
Monteux probability of them staying
multiply it with the customer lifetime
value then we know how much we will gain
as a business from doing the treatment
subtract from it the cost and that is
the net effect of our treatment and as a
business we can induce the best one of
that result so while our model predicts
uplift the policy of doing actions we
need to do perform on the final net
results then back to predicting the
uplift there are two steps one first
transferred outcome and meanwhile added
will also deal with transsexuals so what
predicting transferred alchemy is is
this formula described in newspaper we
actually changed from a classification
problem predicting retention yes or no
to a regression problem where we predict
uplift as done by this formula where Y
is what or someone was retained or not W
where they were treated or not and a
probability of getting the treatments
and if you fill in
for example if ideally treatment
probability is 0.5 if you fill that in
in the formula you'll get the 2 minus 2
and 0 if you got treated you get a
regression level of 2 if you retreated
anywhere trains you get a regression
lave of two if you were in a control
group and so not read it and then you
still stay as a customer you get minus 2
so it can feels like we we don't want to
have that we don't want to treat those
people and if you churn always get 0 to
see this working less with these results
in predicting the uplift because uplift
should be between minus 1 and 1 and not
to to a handle for for cases to ramp if
we've lost cases you've got a single
user with certain features and that
person hypothetically is both in the
treatment group and in the control group
and then so and both actually churn both
will get a label of 0 the your machine
learning model well it's a regression
problem so it solves for root mean
square error for that set of features
can only give one prediction if both
samples have labeled zero the best thing
your model can predict is also 0 which
is doublelift because both the treatment
and control deterrence there forever the
one you treated actually was retained we
had we'd give that sample a label of two
so for the same treatments we've got one
sample label too and one sample label 0
so fee for root mean square error the
best thing the model would predict for
that point in feature space s plus 1
which is the uplift because given the
treatment actually caused that person to
stay inversely if someone not giving it
treatment if some if someone not giving
it giving it treatments they returned
and staying in the control group
actually they will change you get to 0-2
so you then go to minus 1 well the
so-called sure causes so doesn't matter
if you give them a treatment or not
they'll stay anyway one sample will get
the nape of 2 or minus 2 and then you
end up again at 0 but this way I've now
explained it with one person so we have
like 100% or 0% of uplift this you have
you can also feels like what if your
groups of
people and only a fraction of those
people will be retained a place will
actually be halfway well maybe it
slightly to watch one or slightly
towards minus one but this also I now
explain it with just one treatment you
can also generalize it to multiple
treatments so we can include our
telemarketing email and the visiting
door-to-door and it just becomes this
matrix so using this stress for outcome
outcome transformation we can then
change our labels we got all features
and we know for every sample we have in
our data set which treatment they got
and for each treatment doing nothing
getting email telemarketing or
door-to-door we know if they were
retained or not and using this table we
can transform it into our new data set
where feedback on being in the control
group actually is information for every
other treatment well and feedback on
specific treatments is only what comes
in a new data set only a label for that
specific treatments we also see what in
our so we now have instead of
classification problem which ways to
regression case and now we actually have
a multi output regression case and in
that new output regression case they're
missing labels there are the so called
counterfactuals we gave someone an email
but we didn't call them and we can't
afterwards have them in the same
situation also call them so and actually
those are the treatments we are
interested in so we need to deal with
that and that can be well if you have
for example a neural network we have
three outputs three regression outputs
predicting the uplift and have these
labels what we can do simply they always
make a mask define which labels we
actually do know and put the other ones
on zero and if we then multiply output
of our model with that mask the output
of the model for our current fax shows
the treatments we actually didn't know
any don't know anything about but
multiplying at zero they become our zero
and in our label set are also zero so
the model will not get any feedback on
those but it will get feedback on
information we do have
the model is taken we ignore any output
of the model for treatments we didn't
observe and we only trained it on the
data we do have and then of course
during inference time we just take half
of it and take this output as our
fixative lift so the first issue us to
predict churn I have now it's clear that
we shouldn't predict churn because then
well I just explained why we shouldn't
return and better is to predict uplift
and that's can be done using a transform
outcome trick and we multiply it by
Christmas lifetime value and cost to get
our predicted action at a closed loop
back to the casino because our customers
have different leave which we can pull
on and every customer has a different
reason why how they behave on and those
and after we've pulling those levers
giving those treatments who get feedback
which can then be used in a model in a
new training loop to get make better
treatments for the next versions so
we've got our reinforcement learning
setup and our different ways of defining
reinforcement learning setup but here
we're looking we're using complex the
features of the user we have in certain
set of treatments so it's the naughty
unbanded so this is the contextual
bandit solution approach the last part
in previous expression else are included
masks to deal with the current fetch
roles so this the final picture after
first issue is like this yeah so it is
reinforcement learning setup there are
two important things one is actually the
predicts is we make on that uplift
should actually be quite positive if we
predict it wrong we do the wrong action
another thing is when we're doing those
actions we get we'll get feedback so
it's also really valuable to get quality
feedback and it brings us to the second
and the third issue of a second is to
assume correlation and causation if we
look at a data sets of all kind of
features and labels the only thing we
can observe are correlations there are
no causation in just correlations those
correlations really have predictive
power but what you're going to do is
we're not going to observe
of marketing departments giving
campaigns and then some people sure name
no we want to change the treatments so
we want to know if I change this
treatment give another treatment to
someone what will then be the effect so
we're interested in prescriptive power
for which we need the causal link so in
so I do here a calls a graph where the
features influence the retention rate of
someone and also the treatment
influences the retention rate of someone
then we are interested in this edge
between treatment and retention and and
this set up the correlation between
those two actually is the causation
however in the past the company has of
course done campaigns to specific groups
of people and the model we're currently
building the whole idea is that we learn
to give which treatments based on
features of user so our model will make
causal dependency between the features
and the treatment and in this case
correlation is not causation anymore
because there's a backdoor between the
treatment and retention and when we look
at the data we see the combined effects
of these two while we're interested only
in the green one but yeah so how do we
get that one the different techniques
that to get only the causal link and
they all boil down to well removing the
problem that red edge between features
and treatments the feature treatment
bias the simple thing you can do is have
random trial groups so you just make
yeah you give a random sample of your
customers one treatment random sample
you don't give treatments and so on for
all treatments that's nice simple
straightforward but where that means
we're throwing away all our historic
data it's quite expensive experiments
and we just have to scribe a nice
feedback loop of learning system and now
we just doing random of trials again so
we lose that another approach is to
change the features change features such
that you do have the predictive power of
attention that you don't have predictive
power on the treatment and that can be
done by either selecting a few features
so you remove the best predictive
features to the three
or by doing encoding actually quite
fancy ways where you can change the
feature set all your features you encode
them in a new encoding which is
predictive for treat for the retention
rate but not predictive for with
treatments however you can only do it
once
there's as soon as you have made a model
and an encoding you recreate it the
causal link between the features and
treatments and when you're changing the
features you're restricting your
predictive power so what should be on
the third place causal inference is the
way we have to look at which is might be
a little harder to model with actually
solves the problem we want to solve and
that's called inference in nique one of
them is the in first offense weighting
and it works by creating a model which
learns how strong the dependency is
between the features and treatments you
can regard it like this actually they
are for some features like some age or
location some treatments have a high
probability of being assigned than other
treatments so you get like this dense
plot and a dense plot is what the more
your propensity model will learn or you
can n do is take that propensity model
and create predictions of density of the
treatment they got for our whole
training data sets and we're going to
use those propensities inversely as
weight so we wait our training sets
inversely on probability of the
treatment they got and those weights
I used by the model to like put more f
more focus on certain samples compared
to other samples so what a more actually
observes is not like the density plot
anymore but away the density plot and
with this way you can show that the
observed way that density plots just
becomes uniform and now there's no
dependency anymore between any feature
and the treatment they got so that
effectively removed the dependency there
but in doing pensive wedding there are
two aspects we have to look at first is
propensity calibration and one is
clipping well if you have for example
some random plot about propensities
where the predicted one predicted one
and the prediction is on the x-axis and
the true one on I axis what you want is
that it
on the middle line because most
classification models focus on ordering
for sample area and the curve is just an
extra focus on if the order of it's good
there's not so much if the precise
predicted propensity is true to the true
probability so we need to calibrate them
to make them more more exact this way
the propensity high quality propensity
are needed to get a good weight is
needed to get a good model
another problem is well if the weight is
1/2 pens for propensity and the
probability goes to 0 you get some
samples with almost infinite weights you
can really over fit on those few samples
then you can to do two things first is
to clip them so you actually limit all
probabilities to be between for example
point of five and they also have to do
it on the other side point two nine five
or you can say well actually for those
regions in a feature space apparently
the distribution of treatments is so
imbalanced we don't have a lot of
information in those regions so I don't
we just exclude those regions completely
from a data sets by putting the weights
effectively on zero so that we then
change our current set up with by making
it a cost model using in first pensive
weighting we just get a nice new work on
the left then we are at the third third
issue if you have your model they
predict our treatments actually
listening to it and taking the best
predicted action because if we well that
would be like a greedy policy or fully
exploiting it we will get feedback on
the treatment we did and we'll learn if
it worked or if it didn't work we will
never learn if there are better
alternatives so what the model will do
is creates its own blind spots for some
regions on feature space will already
always gave for certain treatments for
our regions and other treatments but
will never try something else so we need
to do is we need to balance exploration
and exploitation and it is to be done on
two dimensions first on the treatment to
give to a certain person the next to
choose which persons in the whole
populate all customer base to treat
actually
and for assigning the treatments to the
well selecting the best treatment for a
certain person we can use Thompson
sampling because our model creators this
obliterate for example this small table
but those values are actually not so
much the true uplift point is the most
likely uplift and underneath those most
likely uplift there's a distribution of
possible a possible uplifts so come for
this case the the email is quite well it
says negative uplift but the
distribution really wide so actually
quite uncertain about it it could have
really positive big positive impacts
using Bayesian modeling we actually can
get these distributions out of a model
and then what tone so sampling is
instead of taking that mode like most
likely a bifs
for certain person will do free on this
free random draws from each of those
distributions of one random draw for
each individual distribution so yet
maybe for email actually you get random
draw at 0.5 of that lift we combine that
with the custom lifetime and the cost of
treatment to get the net result and base
our policy on that if we would have a
different customer with the exact same
distributions we might get totally
different treatments and what is you can
see this working as well as it is in
general we're going to you will can
apply the treatments which work best but
some treatments might have some
potential we are uncertain but actually
on the positive side book we'll try some
more of those to discover new treatments
which might work really well and we're
that way with a feedback loop our model
will actually learn if that potential
actually is true or is just model
uncertainty which then can be lessened
by retraining and the next step is well
as company you can well if we determine
the best treatment for every customer we
got really big row forever got along a
big set of customers as a company you
can't give everyone the best treatment
you need to choose there's a limited
budget so what you usually do is
regulate as normally as you descend
you sort your results descending order
you picked the top about 100 maybe 1,000
or 10,000 matters on how many how much
money you have and three-dose but then
again that can cause us to focus or
apply only treatments in a certain area
of a feature space we still want some
randomization now that can be done by
so-called predictor being the results
where we take for example five percent
of all our results of our customers and
we replace those values by a random
value drawn from a lot of all the values
in do we have so the distribution of
value stays the same but 5% of the
values oh that's randomized if we look
at the histogram will mean like for any
bin we we take 5% of that that will be
disputed across a lot of bins and it's
of course done for all being so every
bin any bin we draw so it doesn't matter
if we have 5 10 100 bins every bin will
have five almost five percent of values
which are a randomly drawn from all
other from the whole population and in
that way we can go to the business like
this is the really the best list and in
business has a certain then certain
bridge yet a certain way of finding out
how many treatments they can do they'll
go from the lid through that list from
top to bottom and doesn't matter how far
they go they will always have five
percents random trials of other people
which then helps us in the model
retraining and then of course that if
it's 5 percent or 10 or 50 or 1% that
the term that's of course based on how
certain you are that your model works so
in them they can focus on take that bin
anyway we have got our final solution
where we can then includes our
exploration and exploitation balancing
in by putting in Thompson sampling and
participating our results and also
having using a Bayesian model and in
that way we also covered our third issue
and it brings us actually to
a final complete solution where we have
our contextual bandits using uplift
modeling causal inference technique and
Thompson sampling in one nice package
which I think well which is I think the
best way to prevent churn in the company
and it brings to conclusion
so our end questions
[Applause]